now to a historic announcement on
student loans expected today president
biden will likely announce a plan to
forgive up to ten thousand dollars in
student loan debt for millions of
americans student loan payments will
also be deferred until january nancy
cordes joins us from the white house and
nancy this is a little politically risky
it is jamie what it means in the short
term is that tens of millions of
americans will see their student loan
debt cut in half or eliminated all
together this is a move that some are
going to hail as historic others will
slam as an inflation increaser and that
is the reason it took this president so
long to make it
months of uncertainty are over president
biden is expected to announce today that
the government will forgive up to ten
thousand dollars in federal student loan
debt for americans who make less than
about 125 000 a year americans like dara
zucker i'd like to see the ten thousand
dollars go away dara borrowed forty
thousand dollars to get her degree she's
been making payments since she graduated
in 2016 but with all that interest she's
barely made a dent i think it is
predatory of colleges and schools to go
after
kids who may not have ever had
any understanding of how finances work
the president has been feeling the
political pinch from both sides of his
own party with some progressives pushing
to wipe out student debt altogether
right now student loan debt is holding
back people who are trying to buy homes
it's holding back people who are trying
to start small businesses it's even
holding back people who want to start
families but some democrats in
battleground states and many republicans
warn of unintended consequences i worry
that
we say to colleges charge whatever you
want we're going to forgive the loan
canceling student debt would also be
grossly unfair
to the americans who worked hard for
years to pay off their loans today's
moves won't apply to students who are
about to take out loans that's the
challenge here is that you potentially
might spend 360 billion dollars of
taxpayer money at the end of the day you
haven't altered the trajectory of
college costs for millions of american
families that are going to be going to
college in the future
that is a tougher problem to solve but
progressives argue at least for now this
move helps to level the playing field
president biden is also expected to
announce today he is extending the pause
on federal student loan payments for
another few months that's the pause that
has been in place since the start of the
pandemic tony
all right we'll keep following it nancy
thank you very much